[Música]
a
época é
e eu nunca imaginei que o estudo de como
melhorar nossa lógica de viver em
cidades tivesse tanto a ver com a
contemplação do mundo interno e da
meditação e do autoconhecimento
mas foi justamente quando eu unir essas
duas coisas que eu tive o que talvez
tenha sido o maior Insight da minha
história de pesquisadora sobre as
cidades
a minha jornada começou há algum tempo
um bom tempo na verdade eu já contei
essa história traz vezes mas dessa vez
eu quero contar ela de um jeito
diferente
em 2008 eu vivia uma crise muito
profunda na minha vida porque eu tinha
conquistado tudo que me contaram que era
Sucesso
já fez uma boa faculdade de jornalismo
estudado em boas escolas
trabalhava na maior Editora da América
Latina tinha tido uma breve carreira já
na indústria do jornalismo
tinha tudo para crescer e para
florecer nessa carreira é dentro da
indústria Só que essa busca por atender
critérios externos do que era felicidade
do que era sucesso foi me afastando do
meu mundo interno foi criando uma cisão
com a minha espontaneidade
a pressão mais natural é mais verdadeira
e essa cisão foi me deixando muito
doente muito estressada eu tinha na
época
obesidade muita queda de cabelo um
problema de saúde Sério que me fazer
desmaiar com alguma frequência
é muito sofrimento muito estresse e essa
ideia de sucesso de felicidade começou a
levar ele lá na minha frente
e eu não tenho um dia que alguma coisa
Precisava mudar na minha vida
e aí uma noite uma amiga muito querida
chegou na minha casa pedalando a
bicicleta dela com sorriso toda suada
feliz da vida contando do caminho tinha
feito com vitalidade com saúde com
energia e eu pensei Ah isso isso que eu
vou fazer vou adotar esse meio de
transporte e ver o que acontece
O
Dani o que começou a conversar comigo e
que eu entendi muitos anos depois foi
uma revolução cognitiva
porque enquanto eu ia de carro para
redação todos os dias e vive a sempre os
mesmos episódios de estresse as mesmas
buzinas nos mesmos semáforos e fui
introjetando essa experiência diária nos
meus hábitos e chegava no meu trabalho
sempre estressada com baixa vitalidade
enxergando poucas soluções para os
problemas que eu tinha tendo pouca
criatividade talento tem boca espaço
mesmo na minha mente dentro de mim para
Inovar na forma como eu fazia as coisas
como eu comecei a pedalar isso se
transformou
porque aquele mesmo caminho que eu
percorri a todos os dias foi abandonado
para uma diversidade enorme de
possibilidades
de cá o
Edi vielas que ver descobrindo parando
na feira para tomar um caldo de cana
conhecendo histórias
exercitando o meu corpo tendo mais
vitalidade e nisso eu chegava no meu
trabalho com outra qualidade de mente e
essa outra qualidade me fazia Inovar
enxergar outros caminhos possíveis
até que isso foi transformando a minha
forma de trabalhar né em poucos anos eu
fui me desligando da indústria Criei um
projeto autoral chamado cidades para
pessoas
viajei pelo mundo e pelo Brasil foi para
mais de 100 destinos
investigando novas formas de viver em
cidades expôs na Bienal de Arquitetura
desconstruir ia para empresas
treinamentos empresas em prefeituras e
tudo isso foi me mostrando que as
ferramentas que eu tinha como jornalista
e escritora e agora poderiam ser usadas
em uma diversidade de possibilidades de
trabalhos aquele mesmo caminho que eu
percorri ia foi abandonado para criar
diversas possibilidades de caminho de
resistência de vida de rotina de
cotidiano em uma das coisas que eu
percebi nessa investigação sobre a vida
urbana é que as cidades Que produziam
estresse
mal-estar tinham situações de
desigualdade social tinha muita miséria
em geral eram cidades em que a maioria
das pessoas fazer a poucas coisas no seu
dia eu ia para escola e voltava e eu tô
trabalho e voltava liberavam
deslocamentos longos e muito demorado
enquanto que as cidades que produziam
bem-estar satisfação
vitalidade e longevidade
criatividade
prosperidade inovação eram cidades em
que a rotina das pessoas está cheio de
coisas uma ida ao parque uma corrida na
beira do rio
uma remada de caiaque ou até mesmo uma
nadada dentro do Rio um piquenique na
hora do almoço
é isso que produzir a cidade melhores
uma variedade de atividades é uma rotina
um dia a dia Urbano positivo em
detrimento de uma vida urbana negativa
né isso é muito sério porque as maiores
causas de morte no mundo tem a ver com
nosso estilo de vida Urbano
câncer doenças casa em vários acidentes
até mesmo a pandemia dão é criar um nós
Urbana positiva é
voltar a conectar as idades com a vida
mesmo né e eu fui percebendo que é a
isso que fazer contra cidades
melhorassem criassem um ciclo Virtuoso
ou seja fossem todo de um pouquinho
melhores em vez de viver em um ciclo
vicioso todo dia um pouquinho piores foi
quando eu descobri que existe inclusive
uma ciência que é o neuro-urbanismo
que vai estudando a quantidade de
experiências que vamos tendo na nossa
cidade e entendendo como que elas ficam
gravadas nas nossas redes neurais estão
experiências de prece um trauma no
trânsito deixam certas marcas
a presença de bem-estar contra os
inovadores encantadores de um banho de
rio de um passeio de bicicleta vou
deixando outra qualidade de marcas isso
vai criando um padrão nelweld
funcionamento
bom então foi aí que eu fui entendendo
que as cidades estão refletindo sempre o
mundo interno das pessoas que vivem
nelas o a consciência das pessoas que
vivem nelas então você tem
congestionamento na rua é porque
provavelmente tem um congestionamento
neural de estresse de sobrecarga dentro
das pessoas
desistem rios canalizados e completados
existe uma dificuldade interna de lidar
com emoções com sentimentos e existe uma
dificuldade de lidar com esgoto existe
uma dificuldade interna de ligar para o
conteúdo os densos essa correlação tá
sendo cada vez mais estudada descoberta
esclarecida para a gente entender que o
caminho de mexer de reformar cidades que
algo tão gente porque como vimos há
pouco as cidades estão ficando cada vez
menos a vida uma minutos de reformá-las
É urgente Não é só intervindo na cidade
não é só melhorando a qualidade da
mobilidade urbana não é só melhorando os
espaços públicos é tão bem mas é também
mexendo no mundo interno das pessoas e
eu vejo que tem três itens três chaves
fundamentais que podem ser viradas nessa
transformação
a primeira delas é a percepção
O que é aquilo que dentro das minhas
experiências eu estou aprendendo da
realidade ali como no exemplo do carro
para bicicleta quando a percepção
ampliou o repertório ampliou o espaço do
que era possível ampliou
segundo. É o paradigma é aquilo que eu
entendo que é normal o que não é normal
que é certo o que é errado é que é
aceitável que não é aceitável
então quando a minha percepção mudou ou
no meu repertório do que era trabalho o
que era rotina do que era normal do que
era a forma de lidar com a saúde foi
também se transformando e o terceiro.
São as nossas ações
especialmente os nossos hábitos
então é aquilo que entra como a gente
processual que entra e como que a gente
devolve isso na forma de hábitos um
hábito é um comportamento Rei um número
suficientemente suficiente de vezes é
para posicionar o álcool automático
a e tá grande maioria do nosso dia é
ocupada por hábitos é ocupada por nós
funcionando de um jeito padrão que a
gente nem pensa mais eu já faz e esses
hábitos podem estar ligados ao nova vida
urbana aqui é positiva ou é uma vida
urbana que a negativa então mexendo a
percepção que formal Paradigma e
transformar os hábitos são três pontos
de mudança no mundo interno podem
interferir muito na lógica das cidades
especialmente neste momento em que todo
mundo tá tendo que mexer nessas três
coisas ao mesmo tempo por conta da
pandemia todo mundo tá percebendo as
coisas de um jeito diferente tá
entendendo trabalho vida cotidiana de um
jeito diferente e tá mudando seus
hábitos
então eu torço para que a gente possa
aproveitar essa oportunidade e de fato a
trabalharem cidades melhores para todos
nós Um grande abraço a todos muito
obrigada
E aí
[Música]